Welsh offer singer Catherine Jenkins has
done a recording of the Anthem with us
now hi Catherine good to talk to you Obe
of course how much of an honor was it to
be asked to do this
oh you know a massive honor I was
actually I was recording something in a
little rural Church in Sussex
and we got the call from uh from the BBC
saying that they would like to play the
very first version of God Save the King
on BBC Radio 4 and would I be able to
record it for them
so we stopped what we were doing
we held a minute silence and we prayed
for him I'd see the queen and we prayed
for the king and then and then I just
sang it and it obviously very emotional
but a huge honor
I'm I'm sure I've heard you talk
previously about having matched the
queen
yeah um I feel you know very very lucky
to have met her over the years and to
have sung for her from you know things
like her Diamond Jubilee and platinum
Jubilee festivals of remembrance
um in the gardens here at Buckingham
Palace for the coronation concerts and
then in a sort of more more private
settings as well and you know it was
such a massive fan
um hugely inspired by her and her work
and her face
[Applause]
um and you know some incredible memories
of getting to sing the national anthem
for her
you're involved with the Jubilee
celebrations weren't you
I was actually singing at the uh at the
Platinum Jubilee celebrations at Windsor
Castle
um so I was involved in that which was
so special to even you know to be
involved in that
um and of course Her Majesty was there
and she was looking she was looking
wonderful and all of the audience were
just so thrilled to see her but now even
more poignant when I look back at that
because that was the last time that I
sang for her and as she was leaving and
driving around the arena to say her
goodbyes to everybody she gave me a
little wave which was really special and
something I'll I'll always cherish now
well I'm sure that I'm sure that's true
have you met King Charles
I have
um through different charities but um
especially with things like
um the British forces Foundation which
he's patron of and I'm a trustee of and
you know I've always admired the way
that he he really cares about these
things
um you know it's hugely dedicated and
that's why I think he's going to be a
wonderful Monarch
um I you know I think he's going to
bring a lot of heart into it
how much
um
how much did the queen mean to you and
how did you react when you heard the
news Catherine
um I you know I've always been such a a
massive fan of his as I said you know I
grew up in a house where my mum and Nana
absolutely loved her so it was natural
that I would be a fan and then I think
over the years of of getting to know her
learning more about her
um I kind of rather than it become
easier to sing for her it actually
became harder because I'd get more
nervous around her
um you know like like everybody I think
we're all you know we're all devastated
at the loss you know she was so
wonderful to us all so yeah of course
you know I was very very sad to hear the
news
okay
um Catherine thank you so much for
taking the time to join us I know you're
incredibly busy and I'm so looking
forward to hearing your rendition of God
Save the King thank you